[Applause]
today's episode is about a whole bunch
of unseen unknown information about my
year and change and what's to come but
first I want to show you something ah
this is a list I wrote at the end of
last year you can call it a new year's
resolution list on the back of an
invoice of a laptop and I wrote an
important list that I thought would
change my life this year I'll read it to
you first finish baby blue which is my
feature film script that I was busy
writing get out and travel more and
appreciate my position at the foam
production house that I was working at
as a director it's super good to read
this because so much has changed and
talking about change that's all tried to
do this just one last time and that's
the intro that I made for you
[Music]
there are so many different parables
written about change and the way that I
look at it is with this one
understanding written by Euripides where
he says do not consider painful what is
good for you and in the most relatable
sense what he's saying is that remember
that time you were in a relationship
with somebody that you just knew wasn't
right for you but at the same time you
didn't want to end relationship because
you didn't want to go through the pain
of the heartbreak you're piteous looks
at this as positive change not pain
that's that's a lot easier said than
done I want to take you on a journey
through the past twelve months of my
life with unseen footage and stories of
how everything has changed for me Maya
started off in a directors film office
in Cape Town it was a giant glass box
actually I lost to directing boards in a
row and then when a big job to shoot the
Indian Premier League commercial in
India I flew to Mumbai I directed the ad
I got shat on by a giant bird I ate
chili that burned my mouth for a week
and then flew home I pulled a giant
floating trash can and got my friend
Jordi to ramp into it to raise awareness
for plastic pollution I slipped a disc
in my back surfing week later I then
employed the directors assistant Luke
and together we had big plans in the ad
world I got a call from Casey Neistat
to invite me to New York so I called
Luke and told him I was quitting my job
and asked if you'd like to work with you
he said yes
a week later I moved I arrived in New
York City on April Fool's it was snowing
I was the reason my back was still stuff
I mean if he started shooting I flew to
Chicago then Montreal and Ireland
Finland and in Vegas then back to London
where we were making Shaun mayonnaise
documentary but I couldn't take the
endless travel and lack of sleep and I
wanted to quit so I flew back to New
York to kick off my YouTube channel to
enter a new state of mind I released my
first video of the Bruce series and grew
by 400,000 subscribers which is hugely
ode to Casey I made friends with this
animator Danny that told me it's
important to remember that your left
want to know something pretty cool
you're loved this gave me confidence I
was then able to meet up with Will Smith
david dobrik Josh Peck who all used to
be fictional
characters from a childhood memory I had
these massive plans for collaboration
but then on that day I dislocated my
shoulder and flew back to South Africa
for cheaper medical and at the same time
I decided to apologize to my ex boss
surprised she was still upset with me I
flew back to the states to finish up
season one of the Bruce series I met
this guy called Willie Morris while
watching the Logan Paul fights and two
weeks later he became my manager I flew
to Island to do a speech about creating
culture flew back to South Africa to
propose to Gabby she said yes she then
buy a house and a new studio space I
struggled to wrap my mind around going
back to New York as so much had changed
and I felt like my brain would quite
literally do a backflip so I decided to
stay here in South Africa for the
remainder of the year and develop my
plan of action for the next year when I
go back to New York and I also try to
read at least seven different kinds of
books but I kept pulling asleep or
losing interest I gained a lot of weight
I lost friendships about three cameras I
lost a laptop as well as the full
suitcase of clothes and I spent all the
money that I've made as weasley snipes
says nobody tweets they fails but well I
would like to be one of the different
ones that do one of the real ones this
past year was one of the toughest years
of my life on the outside it looks like
it's just a story of a guy that changed
from a director to a youtuber but it's
about so much more and I guess that's
what the core of this video is about I
always struggled to let go to say
goodbye to the most amazing and
difficult year that has just passed you
know like most people including myself
we speak about how they would like to go
back in time to change an event or an
action that
fake the present without realizing that
if you create change now
it'll affect the future for yourself for
me and for everyone else around you if
you take anything from this video it's
that in this day and age we have to look
forward memories are great tools for
appreciation and for escape but be wary
of contentment and complacency never
accept mediocrity waited on previous
events you are the legend with an entire
year ahead of you say goodbye to 2018
and welcome on 2019 with the KISS
principle keep it simple stupid then if
you want to release some positivity and
projection out into the universe tell me
in the comments below where are you
where are you going what are your goals
and how you're gonna get there I read
recently and it's been said in life
there's only two things that are certain
and that's taxes and death but now we
know that there's a third and that's
change you brood are change lastly don't
forget to like this video if you haven't
already please subscribe click the
notifications bow on oh I almost forgot
I won't see you next week Wednesday
that's because I'm taking two weeks off
to write a bunch of episodes for next
year and other than that you're awesome
I'll see you when I say
time for a note from our sponsors before
we go any further I want to talk to you
about the value of a VPN a few weeks ago
sitting in an airport lounge and I
logged on to the hotspot like normal and
I got fished I didn't know what this
meant beforehand but I'm super lucky
that my manager quickly understood what
was going on and and were able to shut
it down just before my Instagram got
hacked after this we discussed that he
was like you need to get a VPN and
that's how this Brad deal came about we
reached out to express VPN and how I use
it on all my systems and it's crazy
because I didn't heard that this
actually existed so why do people need a
VPN what does it a pn actually do first
of all VPN stands for virtual private
network and number one of course in my
case is security EP ends basically
encrypt your internet data preventing
others from sniffing your information
over the network for example the man in
the middle attack and then there's the
fun part which is to unblock content and
Y and South Africa we don't have access
to a lot of the sites and something that
I really enjoy like Amazon Prime I go
into expressvpn select my country and
boom I gain access and and wise
expressvpn the best well well the VPN
has service in 94 countries which gives
you loads of options to select from it's
easy to use you can connect with just
one click and it was rated number one
VPN by TechRadar nicely it's less than
seven dollars a month and you get a
30-day money-back guarantee and
therefore take back your internet
privacy today find out how you can get
three months free by going to expressvpn
com forward slash Don mace that's
expressvpn dot-com forward slash Don
minutes to learn more and take back your
internet privacy
[Applause]
[Music]